Monday was Dr.
Martin Luther King Junior Day and as is
the case with almost everything lately,
virtually everyone on social media
seemed to parse out mlks words for
whatever narrative they're currently
pushing in our modern times.
I saw articles on how Mlk was the first
environmentalist,
how he was an ardent feminist,
a communist,
a socialist,
and much more.
The one quote I tweeted of his is
perhaps his most famous.
I have a dream that my four little
children will one day live in a nation
where they will not be judged by the
color of their skin,
but by the content of their character.
I believe this quote to be as relevant
now as it was in the early 1960s but for
a whole other set of reasons.
In the 1960s mlk was fighting for
equality under the law and equality of
opportunity to things that we should all
absolutely believe in today.
Those who judge people by the color of
their skin and not the content of their
character are fighting not for a
quality,
but for special treatment of some at the
exclusion of others.
This misguided principle thinking you
should treat someone differently because
of their skin color or thinking someone
should believe what you think they
should believe because of their skin
color or any other immutable
characteristic is the essence of
prejudice,
which means to prejudge.
This is the complete reverse of what mlk
stood for and sadly this way of thinking
has infected the modern left almost
completely.
This is why like myself,
so many of you find yourselves on the
outside of a political bubble that you
were once safely.
Part of for this direct message though,
I don't want to focus on the flaws of
identity politics.
Instead,
I want to focus on one of the other
topics I just mentioned,
socialism,
and for the purposes of this message I
want to put aside whether mlk was a
capitalist or a communist or a socialist
or a hybrid of any of them.
What I want to discuss is some of the
reaction around the word socialism
itself.
The amount of people I see talking about
socialism positively is actually
staggering.
A tweet I set out saying socialism isn't
cool.
Even got me into a little exchange on
twitter with the official verified
Socialist Party who explained to me that
socialism has actually never been tried,
which is why we don't know if it'll work
yet.
Perhaps they should tell that to the
people of Venezuela right now who were
fighting for food and basic services as
they watched their socialist system
collapse on top of them.
The ideas of socialism,
that the means of production,
distribution and labor should be owned,
controlled and regulated by the
community as a whole are the worst sort
of collectivist ideas which exist.
The very implication that the group
knows what is good for the individual
that we exist to do things for the
greater good is totally antithetical to
the purpose of being human.
It's your job to find value in your
work,
to strive for more than you have to
bring good to yourself and the people
around you and to live as a free person
as you see fit.
The very idea that you should set aside
your individuality for the community as
a whole,
which virtually always turns into an
intolerant hostile mob is exactly why so
many have died in socialist regimes.
Despite the obvious failures of
socialism,
Socialists have no problem using the
freedoms of capitalism against itself.
This is perhaps the most perverse part
of the socialist worldview.
Much like Islamism,
socialism wants to use our freedoms
against us until it attains complete
power.
For example,
they use the tools of twitter and
facebook companies created through the
ingenuity of individuals and the freedom
of capitalism to attack the very system
that they often live in.
By the way,
I'm all for them being able to do this
even if I don't like what they're doing.
That's the tricky part of freedom.
It even applies to people and ideas you
don't like.
Just think for a moment,
if we had a socialist government in
charge right now,
how do you think it would be going for
free expression and free speech?
How tolerant would they be of all the
people that they label,
Nazis and bigots,
whatever you may think of Donald Trump
and the evil capitalists,
are they the ones coming for anyone?
Speech right now,
our reporters being put in jail.
Actually President Obama used the
espionage act to put a record number of
reporters in jail,
and as far as I know,
trump who dislikes the press to put it
mildly,
hasn't put anyone in prison for the
crime of journalism.
Fortunately,
I see a rising tide in America based on
liberty,
freedom and individual choice.
Note how those words themselves are
somehow thought of as evil.
In the socialist lexicon,
liberty,
freedom,
and individual choice must all be
sacrificed for the greater good.
The what they're not telling you is that
the greater good is usually for the tiny
minority in the elite protected class.
Their ideas have never worked and will
never work because a system built on
stripping our humanity is in direct
conflict with what it means to be human.
I've said it before and I'll say it
again.
This perfect system which they wish to
create can never be perfect because we
humans as flawed as we are,
are part of it.
Imperfect beings cannot create a perfect
system,
but what we can create as a system that
always does its best to further the
advancement of human freedom for all its
flaws.
This is what capitalism is,
which is why if you're watching this
from a capitalist society,
you should consider yourself one of the
lucky ones.
Of course,
in America,
politicians don't outright call
themselves socialists.
They say that their democratic
socialists,
this is Bernie Sanders Mantra as he
calls for a revolution of every kind to
be a political,
social or even environmental,
whatever that means.
What Bernie forgets or intentionally
obfuscates is that the democratic part
of this,
of course,
will always be tossed away as socialism
takes root.
It's also why there's no doubt in my
mind that eventually the social justice
movement,
we'll turn on Bernie himself and I think
there's already plenty of evidence of
that.
Democracy is the enemy of socialism and
Bernie's trying to have it both ways.
There's also a reason that the social
justice movement has such a socialist
strain within it.
Both of these movements based on
frowning,
on achievement and accomplishment,
and a resentment of those who break the
mold,
need people to be oppressed or at least
believe that they're oppressed,
to survive creativity,
free thought and the pursuit of your own
happiness is the antidote to both social
justice and socialism.
It's either that or a life of
bitterness,
resentment,
and jealousy,
which in my view is less socialism and
more just antisocial.
Okay.
Joining me today is the founder and
director of turning point USA,
a student organization for young
conservatives,
which advocates for free markets and
limited government.
Charlie Kirk,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Glad to be here.
Big Fan.
That's great.
Young Conservatives.
I thought there was no such thing and
that was like the Yeti or the Unicorn or
Falcor or something.
There's more of us than you might
imagine.
It's not all conservative.
Some are libertarians,
some are free thinkers,
independence,
people on the center.
Right.
We just had that amazing conference that
you were nice enough to come down and
speak at in Florida.
Uh,
2000,
600,
700 students from all 50 states.
And it was so funny.
I couldn't pay the media outlets to
cover this.
Then you know,
I was calling up the New York Times,
Washington Post here.
We had,
you know,
thousands of students given up their
winter break to come here from you and
me and the best speakers,
you know,
that advocate for freedom and none of
the media outlets in the traditional
media outlets covered it.
But it's amazing.
There is a,
there is a revolution happening on these
campuses but it's not,
it's not against,
you know,
conservatives,
all this,
it's,
it's a new train of thought that we want
freedom,
we want smaller government but it's also
fighting the culture war,
which is for free speech,
for diversity of ideas and really
against what these college campuses have
created.
Yes.
So you're in the thick of a lot of the
things obviously that we talk about
here.
So first I just want to talk briefly
about how we met,
because I think it's kind of,
it kind of shows sort of how you operate
and why turning point has taken off.
So we had met about a month and a half
ago at the is freedom Santeria then in
palm springs.
Where you,
where you at panelists?
There I was a panelist and he's kind of
helicoptering around of a lot of friends
that,
you know,
attending that conference you were there
and everyone was like,
oh you got to meet Charlie [inaudible].
Got To be trying to hurt.
We met for two seconds.
You said a couple of Nice things about
me and you're like,
know we're doing this,
uh,
our gig in palm springs in a couple of
weeks,
why don't you come down and talk and,
and then,
and immediately we worked it out and
your guys send me the paper work the
next day and it was done.
And I think that does illustrate
something cause we're going to get into
some of the issues that should be agree
on and some of the things we disagree
on.
But basically you were like,
look,
you're,
you're down for free speech.
That's the main thing here.
And I want my audience to,
to hear you talk about it.
Well,
I,
you're a rational thinker,
which is really rare to find them.
California.
I'm kidding.
But no,
I mean I'm a big fan of the show and I
watch a lot,
every interviews and I know you're,
you know,
you have a huge following amongst young
people and I mean,
I met you,
I met you.
I was like,
yeah,
let's get you on board.
I'm a,
I've always been a gut player for
better,
for worse.
It's gotten me into a little bit of
trouble at times,
but I think it's been positive.
You just have to,
you have to go with your gut and make
quick decisions and similar,
that's where I met kandace owens to
who's now doing a wonderful job with us.
And it took me about 45 seconds until I
offered her a job.
Literally,
I think it happened right in front of
me.
And then you walked up to him.
That's right.
Candice was like,
I just got a job.
And you were like,
let me do something with you.
And it was just like,
all right,
look,
this guy's obviously open to some
different people in total in the Schema,
what's going on.
You need the diversity of ideas,
right?
If you,
if you're in a room where everyone
thinks exactly the same,
that would be a university.
So,
uh,
you,
you need the diversity ideas and you
need,
you need to be able to challenge your
viewpoint around a broader theme of
freedom.
Um,
that really is okay to have that sort of
discussion.
Yeah.
So to,
to illustrate that point.
So then about,
uh,
I think it was the week before
Christmas,
you guys do this.
I was it the largest conservative
college group we're waiting for.
We're waiting for someone to correct us.
We've done some research.
We have never found anything even close
and you'll have 2,650
students from all 50 states.
No one's really found anything even
comparable of size.
So we call it the largest until someone
corrects us.
Well,
there you had some protesters out there,
you know,
they show up all the time to everything.
But,
but there was true diversity of thought
there.
It was also sort of a Reuben report and
reunion for me because prager was there
and Gutfeld was there.
All my best friend candace was there
obviously and and a whole bunch of
other,
sure.
Well trump junior was there.
Is it just a series of people?
I went up there and I talked about being
gay,
married and I talked about being pro
choice and a and a bunch of other things
that if you were to poll the average
conservative that perhaps they're not
for I think gay marriage.
Maybe it's a little,
a little different at this point,
but I got a standing ovation and
everywhere that I lost.
Yeah,
a bunch of times and,
and everywhere that I went for those
two,
three days that I was there and it,
and by no means was this just me.
I mean Ben Shapiro came out,
it was like,
it was like Elvis.
I going to say it was like the rolling
stones is nuts,
but that happened to everybody.
I went for breakfast,
I need coffee before I talked to people.
Yet I'm literally,
there's a line of a hundred people
popping up.
It's like they start swearing.
But that said something to me beyond
the,
that there's something
else going on with young people right
now where they actually,
as the young people say,
they're,
they're really woke.
So what's happening here?
And it's that diversity of ideas that I
think illustrates what makes our
organization so unique.
So a reporter came up to me and he was
totally dishonest guy.
Like,
well,
this,
this feels like a Donald Trump rally.
I said,
how could you possibly say that?
Sure.
We have trump jr.
We have Gorka.
We also Austin Petersen who ran for
president in the Libertarian Party.
Yeah,
we have Ruben who is not a leftist
anymore,
but he's somewhere out there and he
believes in freedom,
right?
We've been Shapiro who literally led the
never trump,
right?
We,
we,
we have a huge diversity.
Dorsey of ideas.
And each speaker was respected,
was given,
standing ovations,
was challenged appropriately.
And I think that really says something
about this new conservate terrian
movement that we're helping create,
which is we don't have to agree on 100%
of conservative dogma.
Let's just get the big stuff right.
The big stuff.
Is America a great country?
Yes.
It's free enterprise a good thing.
You know,
it's freedom.
Something that we should really embrace
as a general idea.
Yes.
It's socialism bad.
That's just pretty much the main key
points in the rest of the stuff we can
argue and disagree with.
Respectfully.
Yeah.
When did you wake up to some of this
stuff?
So just tell me a little bit about your
growing up and your situation.
I was ugly.
Politics,
current,
crazy,
crazy kid growing up.
Grew up in the northwest suburbs of
Chicago.
Um,
always as a conservative Republican
growing up around a lot of leftists and
liberals in my public high school.
And I was young and conservative like,
cause I actually,
I loved history and I was always
contrarion.
Right.
So I'd always be challenging my
teachers.
My parents were generally republican,
right.
They weren't,
you know,
necessarily political,
but they were center,
right.
Bill O'Reilly factor watching,
you know,
Republicans that I always used to say.
And then I would always just challenged
teachers that would say that,
you know,
all conservatives want to do is kill
poor people and you know,
pollute the environment.
The typical talking points,
right?
Yeah.
And being the kind of,
you know,
red bull,
I guess you could say.
I'd always challenged the teachers and
say,
well no,
Ronald Reagan lifted more people out of
poverty than you're crazy social
programs that Jimmy Carter,
it drove them nuts and I found enjoyment
in it.
And uh,
you know,
the,
the further down that rabbit hole you
get,
the more you read Milton Friedman,
the more you understand the foundational
principles and ideas.
At a young age.
I just became on fire for politics and
for economics.
And Long Story Short,
I started this organization when I was
18 instead of going to college and ended
up being a wonderful decision and helped
really place myself in a movement that
was waiting to be grown.
And this is something a lot bigger than
just politics.
This is the fight for the soul of the
country and it has to start on college
campuses and it's really the struggle
for our generation and it's,
it's really,
if you divide it,
it's do we want,
do we believe America's the greatest
country in the history of the world and
do we believe freedom is a good thing or
do we want to go a completely different
direction that looks much more like a
European socialist democracy that does
not honor civil liberties,
that does not honor private property and
really deteriorates everything that made
America great place that that's the
decision our generation has to make.
It's kind of funny,
you're sort of like the non Silicon
Valley version of like Bill Gates or
Steve Jobs,
the guy that didn't quite flattering but
didn't go to college or dropped out of
college and now you're talking to
college people.
When did you realize that that was the
place that this battle had to be?
Right.
The first couple of years of starting
turning point USA,
it started as kind of a generic student
organization,
but just like any good innovator and
entrepreneur.
I listened and I learned and I realized
there was such frustration amongst self
identified conservative Libertarians on
campus that were not being properly
channeled and organized.
They felt as if they were being targeted
and that they were being suppressed and
their ideas were not being allowed to be
heard.
And we made a decision.
That turning point after a couple of
years is let's not just fight the
political war.
Let's double down and fight the culture
war and that we,
we can be the champions of free speech
and we can be the ambassadors of
freedom.
Where really you see these campuses,
I call them islands at totalitarianism.
You know,
their idea of diversity is a group of
people that all look different,
but they think the same.
That's not diversity.
And so turning point has benefited
tremendously over the last couple of
years of really being the champions of
free speech and also saying,
Hey,
we're not,
Republicans were not conservatives.
We're not libertarians.
You can call us all that stuff.
That's fine.
We have members that are across that
whole spectrum.
As long as you believe in freedom,
you believe America's a great country.
Welcome aboard.
Do you think the idea of having that
kind of wide tent is part of the appeal?
Like I think people are so sick of the
labels and all that.
Total is cool.
I spend actually most of the weekend
hanging out with,
with Austin.
Uh,
but part of it also hanging out with
Tommy and candace and a whole bunch of
other people and I was like,
there really is.
And then,
and then uh,
you know,
Alison Stuckey was there and a couple of
other people and I was like,
wow,
these people actually really do think
different things.
Totally.
[inaudible] and my libertarian side
usually goes to kind of where Austin's
that,
but I was like,
we were all having dinner after and
having some great thing.
Then I was like,
this is great.
We're having real discussions about,
we're really big and into this.
Right.
And there is that disagreement,
but if you put them all in a room,
they built,
they get the big stuff.
Right,
right.
You know,
do we believe that free enterprise has
been a net positive for humanity?
Do we believe the constitution is a
great political document that should be
preserved,
protected,
and better understood.
Do we believe America has been a
wonderful,
you know,
net benefit for humanity.
You know,
over the last 200 years they probably
agreed wholeheartedly and all that.
It's the other stuff where they start to
have a little philosophical differences,
but that disagreement is not being found
on the left right now.
If you disagree with one core tenant of
leftist dogma,
you're ostracized.
You're kicked out,
and that shows their,
they're not a diverse political
movement.
The new modern American left,
they're extremely intolerant of
differing opinions.
And I don't have to talk,
I mean I love this,
let you take this day around my agent,
but listen,
I would gladly,
I said this when I had your online last
week,
I will gladly give you the exact same
speech that I gave to you guys
a couple of weeks ago.
I would love to give that exact same
speech to any progressive or Democrat
and you guys are standing ovation,
but I'm not going to get with my maggot
hat wearing the students.
Right?
Yeah.
And that's it.
But you give that speech to the young
Democrats,
socialists of America conference coming
up in a couple months,
you'll get booze and you'll get weak.
Shouldn't hear things.
We disagree with,
you know,
Bolshevik,
forever.
It's,
these people have have translated into
total authoritarianism.
Do you see a moment where both of the
movements sort of where you would argue
the conservative sort of lost their
place,
thus lost the culture war or,
and where the left Sorta went bananas?
Yeah,
I think the [inaudible] has gone bananas
just by default of their positions.
They really,
inside of every leftist is a
totalitarian waiting,
you know,
screaming to get out is a great quote I
always use is because when you argue for
total government power and total
government control of health care in
schools and private economic decisions,
that can easily be translated into the
monitoring side of personal capacity
decisions,
right?
That that translation is quite simple.
And I always say to a leftist that says,
well,
I believe in,
you know,
civil liberties,
but I also believe in government run
schools and health care.
And as I say,
if you don't trust the government to
help you know,
to monitor your own personal life,
why on earth would you trust the
government to run all these other
institutions?
Where I think conservatives have gotten
it wrong over the last 30 years is where
conservatives have become mislabeled and
sometimes some concerns of believe this
to want to do social engineering.
I think I'm going to have angelical
Christian,
I'm a pro life conservative,
but I also believe government should
have barriers and trying to instill
those values upon society.
I think the best persuasion in the best
capacity for good is done through
churches and local community movements
and individuals persuading individuals
and writing books and doing podcasts,
not through government doing massive
social engineering programs.
So I think that's where conservatives
have lost their way and that's where the
left is currently trying to stake their
claim.
Is there anything that you think
government does well?
No.
I think government is a necessary evil.
I think it's necessary for providing for
the national defense because that is
something that whether we like it or
not,
you have to,
you have to delegate some of our
personal freedom to,
you know,
have a,
some sort of a civil society.
But government by its essence,
if you read what Milton Friedman has
said,
they're incentivized to be inefficient.
They're incentivized by definition to
not be able to provide the best possible
good or service for the individual.
So look,
the private sector does everything
better.
Whether it be the inefficiency of the
post office or a Medicare is bankrupt.
Social Security doesn't serve the
people,
you know,
effectively everything government
touches goes to crap.
And the private sector is by definition
more efficient because if you don't do
it well,
you're not going to exist much longer.
What do you think is the best way of
getting that message across then?
Government just doesn't do things well
cause I think it's just so built into
people partly because our education is
term screwed up or whatever,
that they just feel the government
should just do things.
So I saw Bernie tweeted the other day,
this video of all these millionaires
saying,
I responded and so I retweeted it,
which got like 20,000
but we read tweets because it was like,
it's all these millionaires saying we
should be taxed more.
We should be taxed more.
Well,
what's a lectural hippocrates such lies.
It's like,
well,
Hey,
what's stopping you from paying more
money to the irs?
Numb scores,
right?
But it's like,
but okay,
so,
but yet Bernie's tweet get something
like 50,000
retweets.
And not that it's all about retweets and
all that,
but it's true.
He has high engagement with this.
But to me it's just lazy thinking.
It's that is lazy.
So virtuous.
If it's so virtuous to keep giving money
to the guts.
Right.
Why do you need the government to tell
you to do it?
And really at its core,
if you look at the philosophical
difference between really the culturally
Marxists left,
which is what they're becoming and the
free thinking,
individualistic,
you know,
individual Libertarian,
conservative,
right?
Which is the new intellectual position
that is growing,
you know,
quicker than even the left.
It's,
we might want good things to happen in
society,
but don't tell me to do them at gunpoint
and the left on the other hand,
I don't think their intentions are very
good.
I think they want permanent political
power.
But Bernie Sanders for example,
he is so convicted that he is right.
He wants to use the absolute authority
on and unlimited power of the state to
put a gun to your head and say you have
to have a 70% tax rate because someone
is starving on the street.
I would rather live in a society that
has the same tax rate for everyone,
10% and we dig deep.
We say,
are we going to take care of that person
on the street through charity,
through private philanthropy and through
being better people.
And if you look at when socialism's
implemented,
you see the moral disintegration of
society.
You look at Spain,
you look at France,
you look at Europe,
they don't have anything as private
philanthropy anymore.
Private charity has disappeared and
Europe because government takes care of
it and that,
I think that is such an important point
to make.
So,
going back to your question,
how do you illustrate this to a young
person?
You ask the fundamental question,
do you trust the government?
That word trust is so important because
then in that word trust,
that really feels personal,
right?
Do you trust the government?
99% of young people will say no.
Then you ask the next question,
then why do you want to make government
bigger as soon?
And then they'll say,
I don't.
Well then you're not a social,
so you're not a leftist.
Then let's talk about how we can really
shrink the size of government and put
power back into the the hands of people.
And it's important to note also,
even though you think government white
want might want to do something,
it doesn't mean federal government has
to do it.
Local government is much more
accountable to the citizens than some
bureaucrat in d c that you're never
going to meet.
And so those are,
those are arguments that,
you know,
we found to be very effective.
Yeah,
it's interesting you mentioned
intentions and I always try my best not
to impune intentions of others.
I think that,
especially on the left right now,
obviously I think these people have a
lot of bad ideas now.
Of course,
some of them have bad intentions,
but most of them don't.
Most average people don't wake up
thinking I'm going to do bad today.
They actually think they're doing good.
They most of them.
Yeah.
Do you think some of their leaders
actually have bad intentions?
Without a doubt,
yes,
absolutely.
And not all of them,
but some of them.
And you look back to the original
writings and the original thought
process behind the great society and
Lyndon Baines Johnson who bragged on
multiple times that the implementation
of the great society and all the social
programs around it,
we'll keep African Americans dependent
and keep them voting for generations
documented in the presidential record.
Lyndon Baines Johnson said that.
And so I think the Democratic Party is
full of people with great intentions,
but its leaders have realized and
calculated.
But if they can keep the government
programs continuing for just long
enough,
not getting people out of poverty but
keep people survive and within poverty
they will have a permanent political
base.
So if you ask the question,
if African Americans actually rose out
of poverty and saw their wages get
higher and their schools get better and
their communities,
you know,
flourish,
are they going to keep voting for
government welfare programs that are the
basis of the Democratic Party?
Absolutely not.
They're not.
They're going to break out of that.
So I think the intentions of the
Democratic Party,
the followers,
I'm never ever going to impugn them.
I'm not going to call them deplorables
or anything like they call us.
I think most of the followers of
Democratic Party actually really good
people,
but the leaders,
we must question their motives because
if you look at the failures of the
welfare system in this country,
it is undoubtable that they're
protecting a system that benefits them
politically.
Is this also a partly why the media is
going so hysterical right now?
Like have you noticed just in the last
couple of weeks we've shifted a little
bit out of Russia hysteria,
but now it's about trump's mental
capacity and they,
and it's like you can see how they
coordinate it.
I mean,
you really,
if you just look,
you can see you,
they got,
they got like a group text message chain
going,
I'm telling you,
they got like John King,
Anderson Cooper and Don Lemon,
Rachel maddow.
I think they're all just group texting.
I'm not kidding.
I want to have that fear down,
that conspiracy theory.
Can you give me,
when you,
when you start to have all three
television stations open of CBS this
morning and CNN,
you know,
with Cuomo and MSNBC,
morning Joe,
and they're talking about the exact same
thing.
Literally the segments are literally
produced the same.
I don't think that's a conspiracy.
There's gotta be some sort of talking
points memo they send out early in the
morning,
but does that actually you were talking
points memo or just general group thing?
No,
I think it's general group thing,
but I also,
I think they understand that they have
to be coordinated to be effective,
which there's nothing wrong with that.
Effectively we conserve it as do the
same thing without even realizing it.
You listened to rush Limbaugh,
you listened to Dennis prager and you
listen to Sean Hannity.
The talking points are usually quite
similar because you know,
you watch Fox and friends in the
morning.
That kind of sets the agenda and I'm
not,
I'm not attacking the Democrats for
being that,
but if you look at why the media is
going so far off the rails,
it's they will never accept the fact
that this presidency is actually large.
In part a wonderful success is that the
president is fulfilling his campaign
promises.
We're seeing unprecedented economic
prosperity and you're seeing people's
lives actually get better,
and so they have to go down to this
tabloid journalism and report on this
fake book.
They have to continue down this Russia
hysteria because if this president
succeeds,
which he is,
and he will,
what else do they have?
They have gone so far in that this guy
is a psychopathic nutjob.
They will,
they will lose all institutional
credibility and political relevance.
You know,
it's funny,
right when trump started the campaign,
I kept saying that if you keep calling
this Guy Hitler,
you are painting yourself into a really
bad quarter and it cheapens Hitler to
think about that.
Hitler's was one of the worst mass
murderers in human history who killed 15
million people,
and they have people once a week on
those networks,
equate him to the rise of the Third
Reich.
What does that do is it cheapens the
evil of Hitler and isn't that one of the
worst things you could possibly do when
we're trying to educate the next
generation,
everyone's Hitler,
no one's Hitler.
Then maybe what Hitler did wasn't that
bad.
Maybe Hitler was democratically elected
and had a supreme court that kept them
in balance.
You see what I'm saying?
That it cheapens the evil of the Nazi
empire when they start to make these
comparisons to Donald Trump and Hitler.
It's really,
and also the way this stuff just goes
downstream.
I mean,
because then it's you start calling all
your intellectual opponents Nazis.
Then you say,
it's okay to punch Nazis.
Well,
where does that end?
Can we punch the knots and like life?
Can we blow up their car?
Exactly.
I'm called a Nazi all the time and I
mean it's one of the most intellectually
just dangerous arguments to make when
you and when everyone becomes a fascist,
even though there is no evidence of
that.
What really has your political movement
become?
Yeah.
Where'd the words freedom and liberty
and the words that I now use a lot,
how did they get so mucked up that they
started feeling wrong?
You know what I mean?
Or the cultural relevance of things.
Well,
I think,
I think it's starting with the
misrepresentation of what freedom and
liberty really is.
I mean,
the left tries to be the movement of
freedom.
A lot of young people that follow Bernie
Sanders actually think they're on the
side of freedom.
They think that Bernie Sanders is
fighting for political freedom and
economic freedom and that he's going to
fight for the little guy.
When in reality,
when his ideas are implemented,
which he's an open socialist,
the power always gets concentrated at
the top.
The rulers are the ones that get rich.
The people that have the best
connections,
the best lobbyists are the ones that
benefit tremendously.
You look no further than Venezuela or
Cuba or anywhere we're socialism has
tried.
It's the poor people that voted these
guys in the power that get that are
worst off.
And so we have to be able to make the
argument.
Freedom is not only a really cool thing.
Freedom is not only a great idea,
but it actually works like freedom when
implemented actually makes people's
lives better.
You know,
freedom would be a difficult argument if
it was not only like really cool to make
the argument like,
yeah,
you can do whatever you want to do when
you want to do it,
how you want to do it,
that would be great.
But we actually get to make the argument
that in practicality,
freedom is the greatest thing to make
people's lives better for innovations,
for medical advances,
for technological,
you know,
prosperity.
Nothing comes even close to allowing
freedom to,
to ensue.
So what do you say when someone says,
I,
I hear this all the time.
You know,
well,
if the government doesn't do these
things,
these social programs,
or if the government takes away food
stamps or whatever it is that just don't
know if the private sector or churches
and synagogues,
whatever else,
we just don't know that that will pick
up the slack.
And then if that doesn't happen,
we end up with this permanent class of
under,
uh,
you know,
economically underserved people that
have no way
fundamentally disagree with that.
And so this is where the world views,
I think collide is where the left,
they try to build this.
I think a lot of it is trying for guilt,
right?
They actually want to help as many
people as possible.
They feel so bad that people are
suffering.
They want someone else to do it for
them.
So the first thing I do is I challenge
How much money are you giving to
charity?
How much are you doing?
Actually helped the homeless guy in the
side corner.
And then what if 10 million people did
what you did?
Secondly,
never underestimate the good that
Americans will do when people are in
need.
Hurricanes,
natural disasters,
famines fires.
Americans always step up.
Americans voluntarily gave $500 billion
away to charity last year.
Imagine if our tax rate was 10%.
Imagine if there was really a national
rallying call to double our charitable
efforts.
We can easily get away trillions of
dollars.
Wow.
Trillions of dollars.
That's the size of the welfare state.
And I would make a compelling argument
that local churches,
charities,
and municipalities do a heck of a lot
better job of serving the people than
the federal government bureaucrat a lot
better.
You know,
sending money to Washington DC,
is that actually going to help the poor,
single mother and Miami or it's going to
the local Catholic Church and getting
$5,000
which might be a lot of money to you
actually going to help them a lot more
than sending that $5,000
a Washington DC.
I will argue fiercely against someone
who says that a government bureaucrat is
going to help an underprivileged
individual better than a private charity
or individuals helping individuals.
So you said a couple nice things about
trump.
So I want to get into some of these,
some of the specifics on that please.
But,
so one of the things that I've said is
that trump basically was the bull in the
China shop and he just went in and just
up and did everything.
And I actually think that right now
that's a net good because there were a
lot of bad things happening before and
there's some fertile ground for good
idea.
So on that level,
um,
for what's happening,
when I had Eric Weinstein sitting in
that chair,
he said that he would have preferred it
to be a panther and a China shop,
meaning it would have just knocked over
a few things,
maybe not the old.
Sure.
I don't think that that exists.
That's,
that was the point of our disagreement.
I just think it just doesn't exist where
you get to selectively choose which
things are going to be knocked off the
shelves and all that.
Seb Gorka was speaking at the turning
point event.
Yeah.
He's here.
He really Gutfeld is doing this whole
thing about how he sounds like somebody
was doing it on status can stop.
But,
but Corco was saying how trump was the,
I think he said the icebreaker going
sure.
The glacier basically.
And what I noticed though is there was a
theme with the speakers.
Were everyone basically acknowledged
that there are issues with trump.
I don't think anyone went up there and
said this guy is the perfect thing or
you know,
this is exactly how we wanted it.
But there was a sense of this was the
only way it could have happened.
Is that where you would,
so I'm one of the few,
you know,
outward and vocal millennial trump
supporters out there.
Not few I should say.
And kind of this word world,
the conservative punditry if you will.
Everyone tries to hedge,
right?
And there's some good and some bad and
I've obviously gone all in and I'm,
I'm glad I have and I'm happy to walk
through,
you know,
the philosophical,
reasoning for that.
So look like Donald Trump was never
supposed to be present.
United States,
me just look going back a little bit,
running in a crowded field of republican
candidates and announcing the day after
Jeb Bush announced his candidacy,
which I think was no coincidence,
and I think he saw Jeb Bush announced
like,
screw it if that guy's running.
Government took down the Bush,
dynasty that out $110 million to spend
and then took down the Clinton dynasty,
took down the media dynasty in a way
that's totally unprecedented and if you
look at the values that he represents,
in my personal opinion,
he is one of the best chances Western
civilization has to continue.
He believes America's the greatest
country in the history of the world.
He's been a fierce critic of socialism,
has visit this.
Poland was a 40 minute critique of the
fall of the USSR.
He believes that the constitution is the
greatest political document ever
written.
Look no further than his appointment of
Gorsuch and the circuit court judges,
but more than any of that,
he believes that America as an idea,
it must be preserved,
protected,
and advanced.
And is he an imperfect vessel?
Of course,
we're all imperfect vessels.
Does he tweet things that I might not
always agree with?
Yeah,
sure.
But,
but the idea is that he's implementing,
I would make a compelling argument.
He's the most conservative president in
a hundred years,
even more so than Ronald Reagan.
He is doing more bold reforms and he's
fighting to do what he said he was going
to do even in the face of unprecedented
opposition,
whether it be the embassy moving to
Jerusalem,
opening up our natural resources,
getting out of TPP,
getting out of the Paris climate court
agreement.
This is stuff that is not supposed to
happen.
Right.
Do you think Jeb Bush would be doing
this then and give me a break?
No.
Wait,
so basically,
do you think he was the last chance for
conservatives say that?
But I kind of think that's a compelling
argument that know that if you look,
when mccain ran or Romney ran,
Romney was against women with his
binders of women.
They said,
you know,
mccain was racist,
blah,
blah.
That to me,
the most compelling argument is that
none of these guys,
you think Marco Rubio wouldn't be a brow
beat.
Hillary or Jeb would have somehow beat
Hillary.
So that putting aside some of my
reservations for a moment,
this was the only way that any of these
ideas we're going to get.
Yeah,
that's correct.
So we play out the alternative scenario.
Hillary Clinton is president and she has
control of the Senate and control the
house,
and she's just advancing this radically
destructive Obama agenda.
Instead,
Donald Trump,
for any of the disagreements people
might have around him,
the results really speak for themselves
and the economic prosperity that we're
seeing right now that you can the $6
trillion of new wealth created in this
country.
But even more than that,
I'm telling you,
there was a referendum on the ballot and
I was there and Wisconsin.
I was there in Michigan.
I was there in Pennsylvania with Donald
Trump jr for weeks on end.
The people that showed up to vote that
vote in 30 years,
you know what they were really voting
for?
They were voting that America is the
greatest country in the history of the
world.
And here's finally someone who is going
to fiercely defend it against the
permanent political class.
That's important because who else to
represent that permanent political class
than Hillary Clinton?
She was the worst person the Democrats
could have put up in a change election.
Here's someone who's husband was
impeached,
who constantly cheated on her.
She's the most uncharismatic possible
person to put up and here's a guy who,
you know what?
He's going to blow it up.
Great.
That's who I'm gonna vote for.
And you look a lot of what he's doing.
He's sure he has shrunk the size of a
lot of these federal bureaucracies and
he's fighting a lot of these entrenched
media and political establishments that
honestly,
I never thought we would see such a
champion against,
which brings me great satisfaction.
What do you think about the intellectual
side of trump?
Like I get what you're saying that the
broad ideas of freedom to in America and
liberty and those things,
and I basically agree that that's,
he does understand those things.
In terms of just like the intellectual
or philosophical side,
do you think he really has an
understanding of the issues or do you
think that may be isn't even important?
I don't think it's that important.
I've spent considerable time with him
and his family and I can say this,
his,
his understanding of why America's the
greatest country in the history of the
world,
why free enterprise matters and actually
how to benefit country as a whole is,
is just as good,
if not better than some of these
politicians and might be able to recite
all these intellectual and philosophical
quotes because this is a president.
But you know what?
He's been through bankruptcy trials,
he's been through hiring and firing
hundreds of people and you know,
you running a business and me running a
business that,
that develops character in someone.
You just got to say making payroll,
dealing with regulators minus versus
some of these senators that have been,
you know,
orders and thinkers their whole life.
Give me a break.
Right?
Yeah.
So I have a deep amount of respect.
It doesn't bother me that,
you know,
CNN says,
oh,
we talks at a fourth grade level.
Give me a break.
You know,
seriously,
he talks the way that the guy in
northeast Iowa has been waiting for
someone to talk to in awhile.
So I completely dismissed that as an
argument.
And I look at what he's accomplished as
a person,
which is totally amazing and what he's
fighting for every single day.
And he gets the big stuff correct.
He really does.
And I,
and I challenged them on my,
you know,
critics on the right who else in that
field of 17 Republican candidates would
have nominated gorsuch to the supreme
court move the embassy advocated for the
greatest,
you know,
middle class tax cut and American
history,
not back down on some of these core
issues.
It's really,
if I would have said,
here's Xyz candidate,
let's just pretend this is,
you know,
in the Republican primary and in the
first 11 months we'd get this done.
Most conservative pundits would say,
we're at,
where do I sign?
You know,
seriously,
you know,
and he's,
he has,
he has advanced more conservative pro
freedom,
libertarian ideas then any of these
candidates,
what most of these candidates would.
So then what do you make of the
conservative class that hates him?
So I'm talking about like the David from
crew,
that that whole French,
the rest of these guys that really just
hate him.
Even though I agree he has put forth a
lot of the,
I'm sure they've been yammering about
for the last 20 years.
I mean,
look,
I,
I have a lot of respect for those
publications of their history.
I'm just,
I'm challenged to,
I,
I'm really wondering is it a personal
vendetta they have against this guy?
Is it a personality disagreement?
Because policywise and implementation of
the people he's put in place to make
decisions,
the cabinet positions,
I mean this is a much more conservative
president of the George W.
Bush and remarkably more effective than
hw and already in 12 months,
much more consequential than Ronald
Reagan.
And,
and so I,
I'm,
I'm wondering,
I w w the ball's in their court,
right,
because to be so hypercritical just
automatically against someone who is
fighting for your ideas every single
day.
I,
I'm just,
I'm,
I'm really wondering why is it,
is it a personality,
this agreement or is it kind of just,
I don't want to be wrong type of thing.
Like I'm cheering for his demise cause
I'm a po up opposed him for so long.
I think it's also,
I just want to be liked by mainstream,
which,
which is the other thing,
right?
Like I,
I've now created a whole new form of
enemies I never thought possible,
which is like these rabbit welcome to my
world,
you know,
seriously,
like these rabid media leads that are
like,
oh,
he's close to the trump people.
We must try to destroy him.
I'm like,
all right,
fine.
Whatever.
You know,
and the hatred for this man is,
is uncalled for.
Is there anything that he's doing that
you're not happy with?
So I'll give you,
I'll give you this.
That's a great question.
I'll give you something that just in the
last,
and I think you know what you're gonna
say and I'll probably agree with.
Okay.
So in the last 10 days,
so he basically instructed Jeff sessions
we're going to agree on,
okay.
So to me,
states' rights,
if you care about that constitution that
you said he loves so much and all of
those things,
the states should be able to make laws
that they want and the federal
government should not impede on that
story.
We have something called the 10th
amendment,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So in a case like this,
what's happening there?
How is there such a disconnect between
the ideas of freedom that you laid out
so eloquently and then what sessions is
doing in practice?
I,
I can't,
I can't explain it well and I won't
defend it because I don't agree with it.
Look,
I'm a big defender of individual freedom
and liberty and I get a lot of hate from
my social skin are conservative friends.
When I argued for decriminalization of
drugs,
I've never done drugs in my life and I
don't plan to,
but someone wants to do it.
Cool,
right?
Whatever,
you know,
put whatever you want to put in your
body,
as long as it doesn't harm someone else.
So this is something that I think
actually not making the correct decision
on,
but you know what?
I'm happy to say it.
I've said it publicly and you know,
if I,
if I find someone like jeff sessions
who's gets most of the stuff right,
he's been great on guns.
He's been great on some of the other
stuff,
but I don't think he's correct on this,
this marijuana.
She,
and I don't think he's correct
politically.
It's just the majority of Americans
don't agree on this issue.
And to go after people that are
peacefully doing business,
that's really what they're going after.
This is the financial transaction side.
I,
that doesn't make a lot of sense to me.
That's not on the correct side of
economic freedom.
But you know what?
Disagreement is a healthy thing,
right?
And we need to challenge our cabinet
officials and challenge our leaders when
we don't see eye to eye with them.
And I think this is something that I
think runs in the face of some of our
core beliefs and tenants.
Yeah.
It just seems like so ideologically
inconsistent.
I think it's fighting for states'
rights.
He's been fighting for states' rights in
that look.
Even now you've got people on the left
fighting for states' rights.
Ridiculous.
It makes no sense.
Now they're,
they're trying to defend sanctuary
cities.
So now their phones work doesn't change,
right?
It's going against the federal
government.
Right.
But,
um,
I will say this,
I think a lot of it is stemmed from this
kind of old holdover war on drugs that
Ronald Reagan declared in the 1980s
which was an abysmal and total failure.
Right?
The statistics speak for themselves
that,
you know,
the war on recreational marijuana has
not been a net benefit for the taxpayer,
for such society in general.
Again,
I come from the general worldview at the
greatest change does not come through
government policy or through gum and
bureaucrats and sort of be
intellectually consistent.
I want the fend penalizing people that
are peacefully selling,
you know,
cannabis to other people,
whether it be for medically or
recreationally and,
but here's the thing,
I want it to high school in northwest
suburbs of Chicago.
This is the story I always tell people,
say,
Charlie,
your concern,
but how can you possibly hold his
position?
You know that it's always at these tea
party groups,
which I love.
I love the tea party.
I love these people,
right?
But they're there.
My,
you know,
I called them like the hardcore group,
right?
Like they're the Alex Jones,
you know,
flag carry and people that are really
hardcore,
they're really big in the conspiracy and
you know,
there's,
they're always asked me,
Charlie,
how can you possibly be on the side of
decriminalization of marijuana?
I said,
listen,
I went to high school in the northwest
suburbs of Chicago.
Okay.
I remember after football games,
like kids had backpacks full of
marijuana.
Now marijuana is illegal in Illinois.
Marijuana is illegal in Cook County.
And there were cops in our halls looking
for it all the time.
It was not working.
Okay,
let's just put it that way.
The kids who wanted it found it.
The kids like me who didn't want you to
do with it,
just walked away.
What,
what other better illustration of
freedom than that?
You don't want to engage with it,
just walk away,
find somewhere else to do it.
We didn't need to pay,
you know,
the dea or FBI units to go do locker
room rates is something that kids were
recreationally and peacefully doing.
I'm not a proponent of it.
I would support a charity to try to
educate students not to do it cause I
think at root,
you know had a net negative,
but why is it government's role to
social engineer us,
especially when it's a nonlethal
substance.
I always think it's so interesting like
look I now I'm in California where it's
now now recreationally legal,
but I have a medical marijuana card.
Got To hurt my knee playing basketball a
couple of years ago.
The places right over there,
I'd like to walk you in there just to
see what's going on.
Then before it like you're not going to
persuade me to do it,
but I think it's fine.
Like whatever.
I just think it would be fun to go in
there with you.
Yeah.
That would be what was going on in the
camp where my mango hat that would not
go well in La.
Um,
but I think it's funny because anytime
that I ever bought weed illegally,
like when I lived in New York City and
just get it from whoever the weed guy
was,
I don't even know who the weed guy when
exactly,
but I never once in 15 years or
whatever,
I never had the guy selling.
We'd say,
Hey,
you want to buy crack?
You want to buy coke you.
And yet we can go to prescription play.
You can go to a psychiatrist,
push every button rug and it's a hundred
times worse.
And it's an and it's chemically
addictive.
Yeah.
Right.
So look,
I know plenty of people that have had
stories to tell me,
Charlie,
if it wasn't for medicinal marijuana,
I would have gone to narco substances
and I would have been a really a worse
place.
Right.
And so fine.
But that's the core tenant of freedom.
And I think what you're seeing here is
most of our turning point followers
would find sympathy with my argument.
And this is okay,
this is a natural change and a political
movement as time goes on.
But,
and,
and the,
the fact that jeff sessions holds that
position,
maybe he has an experience that I
haven't experienced,
right.
That is really personal to him.
Maybe he's seen,
you know,
marijuana do something horrible to a
family member or people in local
community,
Alabama.
I'll disagree with that.
Probably not right.
But you just have like whatever.
I'm trying to give the benefit of the
doubt because I think he's generally a
good person.
I always tried to give the benefit of
the doubt when people hold these
positions.
Um,
I just think it's not the right policy,
but you know what?
In 20 years you're going to see the
conservative libertarian majority
similar to rand Paul advocate for this.
And then we'll be able to point out the
hypocrisy of the left.
Say,
okay,
hold on a second.
Like we're cool with people being able
to sell it.
They want to sell it long.
It doesn't harm someone else.
Why are you trying to tell me I can't
frack this oil field and the Permian
Basin?
Right.
If you want to have like an intellect,
if you want to be intellectually
consistent,
right?
Yeah.
All right.
I want to do one other thing on the
social stuff and then we'll move over to
some I'm cool with.
So I know,
I know.
I said,
listen,
I never had like I guess agreements that
you immediately sat down.
You're like anything,
let's go.
All right.
Seriously challenged me here we are.
So,
well I don't think this one will be too
much of a challenge,
but I think it's an interesting shirt.
It just shows how things have shifted.
Um,
so at the Republican convention,
Peter Teal and openly gay man spoke
before trump.
He said,
I'm a proud gay man,
got a standing ovation.
Then trump gets up there and talks about
points,
amount trow right points him and he
said,
it makes me very happy.
It was the exact quote he said because
he makes me very happy that they with
the hand,
but okay.
But that,
that the fact that there's been such a
wholesale shift in that,
that even right now,
ted Cruz or the guys that you might
consider a little more of the Christian
conservatives,
which I'm one I could be.
Right.
Okay.
So,
so where you come from basically as far
as I can tell,
don't really see this as an issue
anymore.
Is that a fair,
I think that's correct.
And so let me dive deeper and also pose
a hypothetical to some of the leftest
watching this.
Peter Teal openly gay man gets a
standing ovation at the Republican
National Convention and then pointed as
the,
uh,
you know,
pointed out by the candidate.
Do you think that an evangelical pastor
that was pro Israel that might be a
Democrat would have even been allowed to
speak at the Democratic national
convention or giving a standing ovation?
They booed God when he was doing that
was when it was mentioned.
Okay.
They literally,
what is the shift here?
The shift is the Republican Party is
beginning to realize,
hey,
we're the party of freedom.
Like,
it's cool if you want to do that.
And I think it's,
it's a real sea change because even if
you see ran Paul big,
getting to,
you know,
endorse more of those,
favorable drug policy positions on the
side of freedom or gay marriage,
you know,
you're starting to see a sea change
where it's becoming the sole searching
the Republican Party as we don't under
the last 30 years is what's the one
thing that ties our party together.
Freedom,
freedom,
freedom.
And I think that's why you're starting
to see that.
And the left,
they can't what ties them together.
Oppression.
You know,
like it's the oppression Olympics.
It's like who suffers more,
you know?
And I think that's a really good thing.
Segue to one final point is what I think
is the position that needs to be
articulated better is I have no problem
if,
you know,
gay marriage,
whatever,
like I believe marriage one man,
one woman,
that's my own personal position,
right?
But I'm never going to tell government
to have someone live a life.
I think it's cool.
You're married,
I think it's great.
And you should have all the same tax
benefits adopt children.
It's great.
Right.
But you feel the same way about you?
Well,
it's fine.
It's like whatever,
like,
but that's,
that's more of like a generational
perspective.
Here's where I think Republican
conservatives need to really fight hard.
And I think you agree as the religious
liberty stuff is,
are you going to force a Christian Baker
to make a cake for a gay couple that is
not the same thing as being cool with
gay marriage.
And the left is trying to make a moral
equivalency argument of the civil rights
of the 1960s and someone would having to
violate their religious conscience to
make a cake for a gay couple because
they want to and they want to have
fascism where you can go into a private
company and so you have to produce it
product or service because we have a
certain,
you know,
lifestyle that's dangerous and wrong.
And I think that's where the fight needs
to happen and that's where I think we
can actually win conference over.
Do you think also the technology is the
answer to some of those problems where
we'd kind of sucks that,
you know,
I did in my prager u video from last
year,
which was excellent.
Thanks.
I mean that was the line that really
caught on because I don't want to force
that Baker to do something just as if
there was a,
um,
you could use any example here,
but if there was a Jewish artists who
had a website that they take commissions
for paintings,
I wouldn't want the government forcing
them to paint neo Nazi paintings.
I mean,
it's exactly the same thing.
Yeah.
And would you want to force,
you know,
a Muslim,
um,
wedding hall to have to host,
you know,
um,
someone that is a great critic of Islam,
right?
That would violate one of the tenants,
one of the pillars of Islam,
right?
Yeah.
But for whatever reason,
the left is way overstepping their
bounds.
And the circuit court of California was
like lost their freaking mind seriously.
Where they don't realize the slippery
slope that they're engaging in here
where if you have a private business
with their own private conscience,
they should be allowed to accept and
denied business as they see fit.
Especially if it's business that takes
preplanning like such as a wedding cake
or photography.
The only argument they might make as if
you're,
you know,
running a fast food restaurant,
but you know what,
if someone wants to be a racist or a
bigot,
they have that right.
No one's going to go buy products from
them anymore.
Right?
That's how you win arguments without
having to use the government gun on
people's heads.
Which again,
I think that's the argument that we have
to make.
But if look,
if a gay couple wants to get married,
that's cool.
Like whatever.
That's the law of the land.
Move on to bigger battles like religious
liberty and freedom.
All right,
let's shift a little bit to some
religion.
Okay.
You are a Christian conservative.
That's correct.
Just that phrase triggers a certain
amount of people.
So first off,
what,
what is a Christian conservative?
Which always,
which always stuns me.
So I do a lot of campus too.
Or I'll tell you a quick story.
A lot of campus tours,
and I go through my litany of what I
call hard truths told by Charlie Kirk.
And I'll say,
you know,
socialism is the greatest killer of
humanity in the last 100 years.
And I'll say free enterprise is the
greatest economic system ever.
And then I'll say three words and it
drives them so crazy.
I say God is real.
And it's like they just start shaking.
Then the left,
they think they don't,
they don't know how to handle it and
half the place loves it.
Half the place hates it.
I don't know why that's so triggering.
So I'm a Christian first and foremost.
I believe Jesus Christ is the son of
God.
And he came down and we,
you know,
he died for all our sins and we have a
good documentation of that and we could
debate and discuss that,
whatever.
But as a Christian,
I'm,
you know,
I believe that,
we are called to try to advance the
Kingdom of God and the Ministry of Jesus
Christ as many people as possible and as
peacefully as possible,
obviously.
Right?
So that's how I try to live my own
personal life and make my own personal
decisions as a conservative,
I'd say,
let me go ahead.
I don't see you proselytizing religion
though in the public way.
I,
I've heard you speak before.
Sure.
And I've never heard you pushed that.
So I say it every so often when,
when asked,
but I look at my speaking no different
than sometimes doing a job,
right?
So a plumber,
electrician,
that is not going to tell every person
he turns around the corner like,
Hey,
have you heard the name of Jesus Christ?
You know what I mean?
So you have to,
you don't want to be two offsetting and
off putting.
But I also try to,
you know,
through my,
some of my platforms,
you know,
talk about my personal beliefs,
no matter how triggering it might be to
other people.
And I'm like campus tours.
I try to,
you know,
advance,
but of course I could probably do a
better job of it.
But with that being said,
um,
I would consider myself more as a
conservatorium,
which I find to be a new breed of,
you know,
ideology,
which you and I talked about.
And some people have already been
labeling themselves as such.
And I find no contradiction between my
Christian worldview and my political
philosophy.
In fact,
I find,
um,
great amount of,
you know,
synchrony actually between what I find,
what I believe theologically and what I
believe spiritually and religiously,
um,
to also what I advocate for politically,
which is essentially the nonaggression
principle.
And,
you know,
believing in productive people in free
societies should be able to make your
choices as you see fit as long as you're
not harming someone else.
How did Christians and up as so much of
the butt of what the left hates?
Because you can open up every day
another buzzfeed article mocking,
isn't it?
Right,
Chris genomes and Mike and huff po and
the,
they all love me,
but boy,
oh yeah,
they must,
they must.
The fact that I'm a,
yeah,
it's nuts.
Um,
but how did that happen?
Well,
so I think what happened is that
Christian conservatives fell for a trap
that they really should have rejected,
which is we might hold these truths very
near and dear to our heart,
theologically and biblically and
spiritually,
religiously.
But I think where the line was crossed
is in the sixties and seventies and
eighties where we tried to impose those
beliefs through government policy where
people then inherently have a rejection
to it.
Similarly,
how people are the left and posing their
crazy worldview upon us.
Right?
I think that was a big mistake because
it created this kind of counter
revolution,
which is,
I don't want to have to live the way
some Christian and Alabama wants me to
live.
Does that make sense?
So like it's,
it's the imposition of those values
through legislation and government,
which is something I don't necessarily
support,
right?
So I try to always advocate for everyone
in my political positions through a
secular worldview because that is the
vast majority of people.
And that's the actual,
the government system that we have.
All you know,
decided to create,
we do have a separation of church and
state and we should support that.
With that being said,
I can still have my own personal
opinions and my own personal,
you know,
um,
ways to go about changing public policy.
But when we start to say we should
support this law because it's the
Christian thing to do,
that is,
I think beginning that has turned people
off for the last 30 years.
What does it say also about Christians
that,
you know,
we talked about gay marriage before that
there was a shift.
Sure.
There actually has been a shift.
Now you're basically arguing it's a
political shift or utilitarian.
Yes.
You're just,
you're sort of giving me just the
realist argument.
Yeah.
But is there something else going on
there too,
where there is some,
could be,
I mean,
the tolerance to tolerance in the truest
sense.
And here this is the other problem with
Christians and me being a card carrying
member of this community and I try my
hardest and I fail is,
and I'm around a lot of these Christians
and I sometimes fall into it.
It's this legalism,
right,
is that I'm somehow better than you
because I'm a Christian.
And I really think that's done such a
disservice to the Christian community,
especially the Christian conservative
community.
It's the sanctimonious approach to
lifestyle that I find to be really off
putting to a lot of non believers.
And people say,
well,
I don't want to be a Christian because
they're always going to talk down to me,
or they're gonna make me live by this
set of beliefs.
So they think they're better than I am.
It's a number one critique I get.
It's not that,
oh,
I don't believe Jesus Christ is actually
the son of God,
or I don't believe the Bible.
You know,
those are actually things I think that
can be ironed out.
It's more so like I've always been
talked down to or why when I was a young
kid,
I was in Catholic school and they gave
me these 15 things I couldn't do.
And because of that I rebelled and
rejected.
So I think this idea that actually Jesus
Christ advocated for,
which is,
hey,
I dined with the tax collectors.
I was best friends with the prostitutes,
right?
Like I never thought that they were any
better than the my disciples.
Right.
And I,
and of course I don't live this out the
best I should,
but we're Christians have gotten it
wrong.
Is this fierce fire and Brimstone
legalist,
thou shall all homosexual.
You know,
like that's wrong,
man.
That's not,
that's not what the,
the,
the teachings and the evidence we have
of Jesus Christ's life ever taught us.
He was welcoming,
he was tolerant,
he was accepting,
he had standards.
He was fierce when it came to eternity
in the standards of God.
But he wasn't afraid to go chill with
tax collectors,
which were considered like the lowest
form of individual possible in the
Middle East during that time.
And so I think we as Christians can
learn a lot of that in modern society.
And when we wrap this thing up,
you want to go have lunch with some
prostitutes.
I mean,
if they want to hear about the good news
of Jesus Christ,
even so,
right?
He's sometimes,
some people are like,
oh,
you know,
but the point being is we should,
we as Christians have to do a better job
of not being the sanctimonious moral
conjectures,
which we get labeled at summit and so
much
so when you see a guy like Shapiro or a
guy like prager prager's more than my
heroes,
prager basically a secular Jew at this
point,
but grew up Orthodox Shapiro,
obviously observant,
religious,
there've been orthodox Jew,
you guys basically,
from what I can tell,
agree on pretty much everything
politically.
You're obviously more trump than then.
Shapiro isn't.
I think it's pretty on any given day,
prager definitely is more pro trump,
but does,
does any of your religious differences
does,
I know that doesn't matter to you in
terms of policy,
that's very obvious,
but just in terms of like your humanity
or the way your worldview,
does any of that matter to you?
I've had wonderful discussions.
It's Dennis prager about what he
believes theologically and I mean,
look,
first of all,
I think Dennis prager is like the Yoda
of the conservative movement.
He's like unbelievably brilliant.
Isn't that?
I know exactly.
He,
he's,
he's fantastic.
And same with Ben.
I mean,
I listen to their stuff every single day
and prager university does a heroic job,
but it doesn't bother me at all.
But I'm,
I always challenged.
Right?
So I challenge,
um,
you know,
religious and observant Jews with some
pretty good questions.
I think because I'm very big into
apologetics of the New Testament in the
Christian,
you know,
the evidence for Christianity.
I ask questions,
I'll say,
and then do you believe Paul existed in,
do you think Paula Saaris existed?
And they'll say,
yes,
I'll say it doesn't do anything.
It's kind of like weird that a Roman Jew
dropped his whole amazing lifestyle and
like went all in for this Jesus Christ
thing and then got persecuted,
put in jail six times and then reverse
crucified like with someone do that if
they actually didn't believe this.
That's a provocative question obviously.
Right?
But I love that and I love that kind of,
you know,
um,
discussion and look,
Paul said very clearly in the New
Testament,
blessed the Jews.
You know,
these are your brothers.
There is no new testament,
the old testament.
So we agree,
you know,
with the Jewish people and all that.
And look,
I think we need more Jews to actually
become more observant and to understand
the roots of the Torah and the roots of
what God commanded through Moses and
through David and the,
the major and minor prophets.
And I have such great respect for them
because they've done a great job of I
think awakening,
um,
people that there are,
you know,
Jewish conservatives out there and it's
okay to believe these things.
Well,
it's interesting because there's someone
that doesn't come from this from a
religious perspective.
I agree with the wider principle that
you're pushing here,
which is that some of these minority
communities.
So in this case you're talking about
Jews,
but you referenced black people earlier,
which I want to talk a little bit about
capital working with candice.
Um,
but now I see it with the Asian
community.
I don't know if you just saw it in the
last couple of days.
There's this email that got leaked from
Google where they basically were saying,
we're going to hire people but not white
men or Asian women will be treated like
white women or something.
Something to that effect.
Like this lunacy horribly racist.
It's the real race
and racism though.
It's this kind of like,
it's just there's this ranking of
oppression.
Olympics,
like some of your skin color makes you
somewhat more,
you know,
worthy of a position in the company or
in a university because you've been
through more.
Just because you look different or the
scary part,
especially for the Asian community is
that your skin color and the way you
look is it makes you less worthy because
you're going to work real hard and
you're going to hack the right
decisions.
I mean,
make no mistake.
It's like an anti Asian American
worldview that the left has now
essentially embraced.
It's like,
Oh,
they've been successful enough.
Now we must discriminate against them so
we can help the,
it's like it's,
it's,
it's lunacy.
But going back to your point of the
Christian conservative kind of
Worldview,
I think that there's a lot,
there's a lot of us that hold these
beliefs very personal.
But also that's,
that's kind of where we draw the line
is,
and you know,
we have these personal beliefs and
they're gonna dictate how we want to
live individually.
But how do we advocate for a society
that allows the most amount of people to
advocate for their own personal beliefs,
whatever they might be,
as long as it doesn't harm someone else.
So your basic argument,
and I think you hit on this a little bit
earlier,
would be that the part of the reason
that Europe is crumbling,
which is crumbling,
the West is crumbling except for
America.
Yeah.
I mean,
we're,
so we're taping this,
it's going to go up next week,
but we're taping this today is the three
year anniversary of Charlie Hebdo was a
couple of years ago,
three years.
But today was the day that they finally
caught the guy,
and then there was the shooting at the
Kosher supermarket entire summers and
all that.
Today a different supermarket was burned
down.
I mean,
this is,
this is still happening in Paris right
now.
Uh,
and this is happening all across Europe.
We know what's going on in Sweden.
All this,
your basic premise would be that if they
had held on to some of their
judeochristian values instead of trading
them in,
or what,
what do you think is essentially statism
right.
But yet you're also a secularist,
which is an interesting,
I don't think it's not,
I don't think it's contradictory because
I would make an argument that actually
the separation of church and State found
in America has helped the church.
We still have the highest churchgoing
greats rates in the west.
We still have the highest levels of
private philanthropy have more churches
opening than ever before.
The evangelical community is growing in
most states,
as Alan Dershowitz would say,
the separation church and state has been
the best thing for the church.
Uh,
because it's not imposed upon people.
It's not mandatory.
As you and I both agree,
when as soon as you start to tell
someone to do something,
it becomes a lot less sexy and
appealing.
It actually want to rebel against it.
You want to reject it.
I would argue Europe through their
social welfare programs have
deteriorated the church be as soon as
they start to say,
government is going to take care of
people,
government is going to be the most
important thing in your life.
Government's gonna fix these vastly
complex social problems.
Then all of a sudden the church and the
individual becomes far less significant.
As Dennis prager says,
the larger the government,
the smaller the citizen,
and you're seeing that play out in
France and Spain and Portugal and Italy
where you have individual philanthropy
disappeared,
where you have business startups,
ness totally evaporate.
And the final point is what it really
lends itself to is more dangerous
ideologies to take forms such as radical
Islam,
which is I think one of the most
dangerous widespread ideological
movements happening in the West that no
one is talking about.
And here's what I said.
I mean you're,
you're,
you're a gay guy.
I mean,
I would probably be worried if I start
to see,
you know,
radical Islam start to take root in
Europe.
Right?
You're a Christian.
I'd be worried too.
No,
I mean trust me,
I'm on that program.
Okay.
They want us both that and my friend.
Right.
I mean the,
and that's something I find to be
horribly inconsistent with the left as
they try to be the champions of all
these minority groups and all these
supposed to depress groups yet here they
are kind of joining forces with
countries and movements and you know
theocratic fascists in the Middle East
that give homosexuals flying lessons on
the top of buildings.
All right.
So then how do we,
I spent I think a good chunk,
especially the first year of this show
trying to talk about radical Islam,
making a distinction between radical
Islam and the nominal Muslim person who
practices in faith privately.
However they do just like most sure
people,
I try to separate Islam as a set of
ideas worthy of criticism as
Christianity is and you is and
republicanism and all of that.
Okay.
Versus people versus criticizing people
and treating people differently.
I think a lot of people in our space
have tried to do that.
And you don't get a lot of credit for
it,
but okay,
fine,
I don't need bonus credit.
But how,
how do we talk about radical Islam in an
honest way?
And I do.
There is a differentiation that needs to
be drawn,
but it also,
we also do need to talk about the
broader implementation of an oven,
Islamic government and world view,
right?
So Islam as its core at its core has
always been and will always be tied into
the state.
And as soon as they can demonstrate that
they can be a majority in a country and
not be a theocratic government,
then I'll start to seed some territory
against that.
So for example,
Saudi Arabia,
right?
So if you are a Christian in Saudi
Arabia,
you lose your head.
If you're a Jew,
they'll find your family and kill all of
you.
That's,
there's something wrong about that,
right?
So I think we need to draw a great
critique of that same in Iran,
which is Shia and Saudi.
Um,
which was Sunni.
And there's something really I think,
not correct about in modern society that
you have obviously a Muslim majority
country and you know,
there is no Christians and no Jews and
no churches and no synagogues.
There's something very intolerant about
that.
However,
people that want to reform Islam,
I'm your biggest advocates,
right?
People that want to go through
reformation of Islam and try to
differentiate that no,
Islam does not have to be tied to the
state.
And yes,
Islam can be tolerant of Christians and
Jews and gays and the modern feminist
movement and they should be allowed to
vote and drive and you know,
be able to make decisions that they see
fit and not have to wear a full his job.
I want those Muslims at succeed
frightened that the more radical voices,
which are in the tens of millions,
if not hundreds of millions,
are actually getting more,
more of an audience.
They're there.
They're creating,
you know,
sectors of Europe that are quite
troubling,
that are advocating for the advancement
of these more dangerous ideologies that
support honor killings and don't think
women should have the right to drive or
to vote or to be able to have
representation,
any sort of form of government.
And so I think a broader critique of
Islam needs to be put forth because
they've been doing it against
Christianity for the last 100 years.
I walk into a lecture hall and I hear
about how incredibly intolerant
Christians are and how they're terrible
people find hard stop.
You go to the Vatican,
a woman is allowed to wear shorts and
you know,
a cutoff tee shirt.
You go to Mecca and you're a Christian,
you get your head cut off.
I mean,
you literally can't go.
No,
you literally not allowed there.
They're literally not allowed.
So there,
there's,
there's a discussion that needs to
happen where a broader reformation is
necessary,
but the more radical voices of Islam are
actually succeeding.
Right now.
You look at the most viral,
um,
members of the youtube community and the
Sunni Saudi region,
but they're the ones that are advocating
for a holy war and the extermination of
Christians.
They're the ones that are really taking
root.
We have to support,
we have to reinforce and we have to
really encourage the more ref,
the reformist Muslims to get a broader,
you know,
platform.
But I'm just not seeing it.
Yeah,
I mean I've tried to do the little bit
of it.
You know,
you've done a great job,
some reformers and some ex Muslims and
things like that,
but the problem is that they're
constantly undercut by their own
supposedly their own people.
Yeah.
I left every time is one of them talks
about this.
They say you're a sellout or you are
sure evil or you know,
whatever.
It
does beg the question like that,
that the,
the center of their faith is the most
intolerant city in the world.
Like someone's got to take a broad stand
against that and maybe we'll see it in
the next hundred years,
but how much had been some on,
you know,
the new crown prince of Saudi Arabia is
trying to do some more,
you know,
modern changes.
But you're also seeing extraordinary
radical voices in Saudi Arabia
continually rise up.
You're seeing protests in a ran,
which is great,
but then you're seeing a lot of the
western world not stand with these
protests or see,
president trump has done a great job of
it.
Obama who was totally silent.
So look,
Islam in general.
Um,
there's,
there's wonderful Muslim friends that I
have and productive members of the
American community that embrace this
idea that you can hold your beliefs
without having to have them push through
estate,
which is great.
But you're also seeing the exact
opposite with the,
you know,
the Muslim Brotherhood taking further
root in Egypt and in Turkey,
you're seeing,
you know,
Saudi Arabia want to continue its
influence throughout the Arabian
peninsula.
It's gonna be a conflict of ideas and
it's the largest religion,
I believe in the world.
Correct me if I'm wrong.
1.2
billion people Christianity's right up
against.
But I would argue that Islam has a lot
more power in countries and Christianity
does.
It's a reformation that needs to happen.
So is the demographic time bomb and in
Europe,
is it already too late?
It's troubling.
It's very troubling.
So as a byproduct of supporting social
welfare programs and the sixties and
seventies that deteriorated,
the influence of the Catholic Church and
in protestantism throughout Europe,
and really just kind of making people so
apathetic towards private philanthropy,
apathetic towards value creation,
entrepreneurship rates disappeared.
And you really created a lazy European
society.
Hate to say it,
but they are not highly productive
people.
They take the month of August off,
they have very little ambition.
They're okay being average.
That's not the society I want to live
in.
America's always been aspirational.
We've been the most productive.
We've been the risk takers,
we've been the,
we've been the entrepreneurs.
So because of that,
they've laid themselves to be remarkably
vulnerable to a takeover culturally and
demographically.
And you're starting to see that with the
millions of relocations from the Middle
East of people that don't hold these
views that the Europeans hold.
And honestly they come from a
background,
whether it be Syria or Jordan or Yemen
or Oman,
Yemen,
there's a huge humanitarian crisis
happening.
They've known nothing but government
being Islamic.
And so they inherently support that.
But if they want to go through a
reformation and they can demonstrate,
they can do that.
Great.
I,
I'm,
I'm not seeing that though.
I'm seeing vast demographic clashes
happening all throughout Europe.
There's also an interesting generational
piece to this,
which is that you find that a lot of the
older people that came from those
countries,
you know,
30 years ago,
they actually are more westernized in
their total drain are now they're sort
of making up that there was something
imaginarily great about Saddam that's
correct.
Out where their parents and we need to,
we need to reform the,
you rebuild the califate and very
dangerous.
Right.
And so you look at the reformation that
Christianity right rightfully went
through in the 1500 and 1,617
hundreds it's as soon as you embrace the
idea of personal freedom and individual
liberty and you try to restrict the
state.
So put your,
put yourself in the,
in the,
in the seat of the founding fathers.
They intentionally removed any sort of
mention of Christian dumb in the
constitution,
which ended up being the best thing for
Christianity,
which created the most Christian nation
in the world.
It does America think about how ironic
that is,
right?
Whereas Europe didn't always do that.
They actually created these theocratic
governments that led way to,
you know,
horrible conflict and you know,
ethno nationalism and eventually in the
sixties and seventies like I mentioned,
the huge proliferation of the welfare
state,
which was the worst decision Europe ever
made.
They turned a highly productive people
into a mediocre,
Lazy Society that rejected all sorts of
religion and any sort of,
you know,
connection to higher being and has now
led themselves to a demographic takeover
that I think is the worst.
Some people think it's for the better.
I just don't see any evidence of that.
But again,
there's nothing,
there's,
I get,
I get criticized as being a racist and
all this.
I'm not talking about a set of ideas
that when implemented through the state
have proven to be extremely dangerous to
human rights and economic productivity
and private property rights and really
cumin,
you know,
human dignity.
So when you've mentioned the phrase
oppression Olympics a couple of times,
which obviously I totally buy in on,
which is from your video,
I stole it from you by the,
well,
I think I stole it from Faisal site on
guitars and he probably stole it from
somebody.
So that's how these ideas get around.
But um,
this idea of this,
this intersectional nonsense,
which is all nonsense,
how do you,
do you think that the average left
person in America that says they're a
feminist and therefore,
what do you think that they don't
recognize any of the stuff that just
said about that?
Obviously don't talk about it or they
might,
they might,
they might recognize it.
They might know about it.
They might be able to answer it in a
trivial pursuit game.
But the question is here.
So your,
there's the international feminist
society,
which is growing huge on campus and I
always challenge them.
They advocate for women's rights across
the world and then they're like right
next to like the Muslim student
association,
which is fine.
They should be friends.
That's okay.
Like,
but why are they not demonstrating wide
said pr widespread protests against how
women are treated in Saudi Arabia,
but the international feminist society
is protesting for against Israel.
It's weird,
right?
It's like because intersectionality,
it's like they have this weird construct
that we must advocate against Israel
because Israel is a friend of America
and America hates women.
It's like this weird,
like I,
I need like this big map.
Like where they kind of try,
it doesn't make any sense,
but where is the outrage?
They say there's outrage when I
challenged them.
Oh yeah.
We're really outraged about it.
Yeah.
Okay,
sure.
But no,
we're,
where's the,
where's the Oprah Winfrey's,
right?
Where's the Hillary Clinton's who spoke
multiple times and Saudi Arabia and took
millions of dollars from them.
Right?
We're women can't drive where women can,
we now that can drive and that's going
to be a real disaster,
you know?
No,
it is because all of a sudden they're
just wait for the moms to get your hands
up.
Hands up there.
The women are,
what do you mean?
Oh,
because they're going to have a total
religious clash about this because Hamad
had been some say it's said by decree
that women can drive and there's going
to be all these religious
fundamentalists that are not gonna allow
it to happen and it's going to be a
total conflict.
They were bragging that women are
allowed to go to movies now like that to
show you how medieval Saudi Arabia's,
right.
But anyway,
Hillary Clinton made this like her
pinnacle,
you know,
point of her campaign is like,
I'm going to really have good relations
with Saudi Arabia.
Her Foundation took tens of millions of
dollars.
Here was a woman that ran on the idea of
like feminist representation.
Right?
And she can't critique Saudi Arabia
once.
Right.
But she critiques Israel for the
settlements.
Right.
So I think there's unbelievable
hypocrisy there,
but it's not just Saudi Arabia,
which I'm focusing on.
It's Egypt.
It's a rant.
It's Iraq,
which is changing.
It's Syria,
it's Jordan,
it's on mine.
It's Yemen.
The only countries that get it.
Right.
Or Katar.
And maybe the UAE.
But you have,
you have a geographic dis,
you know,
disposition of hundreds of millions of
square miles where women cannot vote.
Women cannot own property.
Women cannot start businesses.
Women cannot serve in government.
Men have total and absolute control over
society.
Gays.
They asked [inaudible] shot.
They said,
how do you,
how do you treat?
Don't have it.
No.
Yeah.
How do you treat gays and your society?
We do not have homosexuals in our
country.
That's great.
Where's the,
where's the LGBT international society
protesting against that,
right?
Yeah.
It's like they have this kind of like
handshake,
like we're not going to mention this.
It's all good that I can't stand
anymore.
And then what?
What country did they hate the most?
Of course it's Israel where they were
days are open or openly productive
members of society.
I think they can marry in Israel.
I'm not sure,
but I,
the West has been the best to women and
to gays and yet they want to destroy the
last,
which doesn't make any sense to me.
By the way,
you mentioned settlements a minute ago.
I think that Jesus guy you referenced
before,
I lived in a town called Bethlehem and
where he was born in that lands in the
West Bank.
Yeah,
exactly.
Jesus of Nazareth.
Minor details here,
right?
Yeah.
History though.
He's just lost on people,
right?
Is that like,
to me that's one of the most horrible
things like that.
People don't know basics about history
and even it's,
it's the basics,
but it's just like the ignorance of
understanding the,
the blessings we have,
the live in western civilization and how
unique what we really have here as a
country and it's being taught in our
universities how America is a racist,
xenophobic,
imperialist,
horrible country,
and you really have to try.
It takes effort to try to make that
argument because America has been one of
the greatest,
if not one of the greatest ideas ever
implemented in human history and civil
society.
It's had more respect for human rights.
Instead more economic productivity.
We have freed more people from serfdom
and from bondage in any other country.
We voluntarily sent our citizens and our
civilians and our soldiers to die for
the freedoms of others not asking for
anything in return.
You look at the Korean War,
we send,
you know,
our boys from Iowa,
Kansas,
South Carolina and Florida to go die in
the Korean Peninsula,
50,000
of them so that South Korea can exist.
We asked for nothing in return if we
were in pure lists where the worst
imperialist ever.
Right?
And so yet it takes the effort to really
look at,
look at history and say that we're a
horrible place.
And this is what the modern American
left is trying to do is like,
remember when I send the beginning of
the video,
we have a choice.
We can either go the way of Europe and
totally fundamentally transform this
country and embrace a set of ideas we've
never had.
Or we can defend respect and advanced
American ideas here and really try to
make the 21st century the greatest
who've ever had.
Is there an inherent risk in some of
that though that yes,
there are things like South Korea,
that workout.
There's also,
it's on foreign policy.
I mean there's a lot of instances we've
had,
we tried the kinds of blunders,
I mean I'll,
rack war was a total mistake.
It was a disaster.
So they,
so that's just the inherent risk in this
space.
I don't know.
That was sanctioned by the way,
by Congress and the Senate and sure the
united,
it wasn't,
it wasn't actually an effect of war of
authorization.
It was a conflict.
But so what I meant there is a broader
point that throughout the 20th century
America has stepped up and fought for
the freedom and liberty of others I'd
ever asking for something in return.
I would argue that Iraq was a,
was a horrible response to nine 11.
It had nothing to do with the actual
existential threats against the
homeland.
That was George W.
Bush trying to rectify a mistake that
his father didn't actually make,
which was takeover,
you know,
Saddam Hussein's empire.
We got next to nothing.
We lost 30,000
American troops.
We spent $2 trillion we didn't have,
and we helped create isis to boot.
Um,
so imposing American ideas worldwide is
not something that I would have ever
advocated for,
but argue what,
when,
when the chips are down.
For example,
you know,
in World War II and you know,
the Nazi empire is on the March and
they're 16 miles away from Moscow and
you know,
Winston Churchill is on his hands and
knees begging FDR to send troops.
Then we send,
you know,
half million ground troops to go through
Normandy.
We stepped up,
right?
And we help push back European fascism.
So look,
there's been a lot of mistakes.
Some of our incursions in Central
America were total disasters,
but net positive America's,
you know,
um,
decisions throughout the 20th century
have helped,
you know,
advanced human freedom and,
and release people from bondage.
So to that end,
you must love what trump's dealing with
the UN,
right?
Oh,
it's fantastic.
Are you kidding?
Really is a freaking all stars.
Here's what I love about Nikki Haley to
my left is people watching this.
How can you not recognize she was
everything you pretend to advocate for?
No,
no,
seriously,
because she's,
she's a son,
daughter of an immigrant.
She's a minority and she's Indian like
from actual India.
Right.
Which is one of their,
I think oppression Olympics groups.
Right.
Well,
you saw this thing like a couple of
weeks ago where they were trying to mock
her for using the name Nikki,
and it's like,
that's what her parents call.
I know me.
Imagine if a Republican said that
there'd be March.
She's totally self made.
Her father literally owned convenience
stores,
started at as state senator ran as an
insurgent for governor twice elected,
eradicated the confederate flag from her
State Capitol,
balanced the budget,
created South Carolina into this
unbelievably prosperous state in a very
complicated political state.
By the way,
by the way,
they always said,
you know,
the south is so racist.
Well,
they help twice elected,
you know,
a woman,
minority governor of a state that you
call,
you know,
the new,
confederacy.
Anyway,
Tim Scott Guy.
Exactly.
Yeah.
One of the only,
there's only two African American
senators and one of them's from what
they call one of the most racist states
in the country.
That's beside the point.
Yeah.
Then she gets selected by president
trump who supposedly hates women,
but he has a represent us in the UN to
go fiercely fight against all these
globalists forces at the UN cuts aid to
the Pakistan.
She is what the left is supposed to
love.
Right.
She is the,
she is this absolute bodymind of modern
day feminism.
Yet they hate her.
Did you see this tweet the other day by
the at Democrats?
You know the official,
Oh yeah,
well all the check marks women have a
qualified woman.
But the bet,
well that of course that's the,
that's like the blanket response but the
best was so it was like,
you know,
do minority women and Brown women,
but the amount of people who just wrote
it all right,
you're endorsing Nikki Haley and it's
like,
man,
you guys,
this is what you idiots have created.
Yep.
It's right there.
They are.
And I can't tell you,
it's really interesting because so many
of our turning point members and our
turning points students,
I say,
why are you conservative?
I'm a student.
I'm not concerned because of the left.
I left the left because the left,
because they have lost their freaking
mind.
Like if they were just like normal
democrats and didn't say the stupid
stuff and an intersectionality politics
and like they argued like,
well we can run govern better,
but free enterprise is a good thing but
flawed and we need pr.
We need to perfect it.
And you know,
if they actually had some humility for
it instead of just like embracing
cultural Marxism and doing the
oppression Olympics,
I think you might still be on the left
instead they created the greatest gift.
Thank you liberals for doing this
leftist.
Cause now we have like former Bernie
Sanders supporters running our chapters
because they are now cultural marxists
that look at people at the color of
their skin by how much value they have
in the world or how great can understand
someone's,
you know,
v,
degree of suffering,
which is everything that Martin Luther
King argued against,
which is everything that is
fundamentally created this country.
And so thank you.
Left us for helping create this movement
for us.
Are there any good Democrats left?
Oh sure.
They're like,
I have my issues with plenty of
Republicans and I'd be more should of a
rand Paul Republican and a libertarian
on board join the,
the,
you know,
I call it on the sif evil empire.
You could join the resist the real
results,
the real resistance.
I mean,
look for the stuff that I like about
Rand Abi at Rand Paul obviously has all
the Libertarians of course,
sadly in that collection of 18 people
that were running against trump,
he was seemingly on the wrong stage.
It's just the party had nothing to do
with that time,
what he wanted.
Even if,
as you've said before,
trump may be doing a lot of those,
those things right now we show you how
complex this whole very convenient.
But um,
the question I think you had was,
um,
but the new generation,
like who do I need?
Good Democrats.
Is there anyone now that you can,
sure.
I,
I'm still looking for that kind of like
blue dog Democrat to rise up and be
like,
you know,
I'm a democrat.
That is pro choice,
which I disagree with whatever that is.
You know,
all these things.
But I still think America's a great
country and we need to like rid our con,
our country of Antifa.
Alan Dershowitz is probably the only one
I could think of right now.
Who was built the way he's getting
kicked out of the Democrat party buddy
abuse.
He's taking them saying this every week
since when has it been a bad thing to be
Alan Dershowitz?
I mean,
the guy is freaking brilliant.
You might disagree with him,
but he's like the smartest lawyer and
human rights attorney that you could
possibly find.
And now the Democrats have been like,
he's our cues being paid by the trump
camp parenting.
Like,
are you kidding me?
I mean,
he's brilliant and they're kicking them
out.
I love that man.
So yeah,
there are some good Democrats out there,
Charlie.
I suspect we could do this for a couple
of more hours,
but I'm only going to ask you one.
Okay.
Because I want this on the record,
on this show,
because when it happens,
uh,
it should be that I asked at first,
you're going to run for Senate.
No,
not for political office.
I want to,
I want to be a commentator and a
movement driver.
Does that have anything to do with the
clown show that that running?
Is that a guy like you who you obviously
have a great understanding of the
issues.
You have a consistent line of thought
whether I agree with you on every far
too principled.
No,
but there's something to be said for
that.
Right?
So I mean that goes to what coworker
said about he's the broker,
right?
But in all reality,
I love what I got to do.
Seriously.
Like every day I get to create a
movement and helps facilitate a moving
out,
create and say what I want to say and be
able to have conversations with you on
all this stuff.
I've met very few Congress people or
senators or governors that actually
enjoy what they do seriously.
And it's always about meeting with
lobbyists or cow towing to leadership
and fundraising.
It just makes me sick to my stomach
thinking about that.
But let's pretend it was a great gig,
which some of them seem to like it.
I don't know why they liked the
corruption or something I like.
Is that really a place where I can do
the most amount of good for my
worldview?
And I would say probably not.
No.
I'd say look,
turning points,
doing a great service for the country.
I think right now I love what I get to
do.
I have,
you know,
have some influence in helping shape
this policy in this agenda.
And that doesn't seem like fun to me.
I do.
It doesn't seem like that would maximize
my amount of happiness.
Yeah.
All right,
well it's on the record now.
It's on the record.
I still,
I hope I don't talk like a politician
to,
uh,
I think we're doing a gig together in
New Hampshire.
Yeah,
that'd be fine.
Not too long from now.
So we'll,
when we get in canvas will be there too.
And Canada's Owens.
Oh,
real quick.
Yeah,
sure.
Let's just finish talking to the
candidate I backhand is for a moment.
So when I,
when I met you that day,
I referenced that and literally a minute
before you had,
I saw it from a distance you,
we can just talk for about two minutes.
And then she walked over to me and she's
like,
I just got a job with turning point.
Charlie wants me to,
you know,
help talk to the black community and
Blah,
blah,
blah.
She's quickly becoming an all star in
this space.
I think she escaped some of the Youtube
Madness,
which I'm somewhat aware of and you may
have seen my insane debate with her and
Blair white and blah,
blah blah,
but she's quickly becoming a real
powerhouse hodel voice because the black
community has needed more p,
you know the Thomas Souls that Larry
Elders and David Webb's and who have
Allen West,
whoever else there,
it's a different generation.
She's coming at it from the firm at
young place.
It's kind of beautiful.
She's unbelievably talented.
I'm spent a considerable amount of time
with her now minus the five minutes I
hired her,
but she's a passionate driven person.
Look broader than that.
She like,
like all of us on our team believe and
understand there is a movement happening
in this country and it's something the
media will not report.
It's something palpable when you
experience it,
you saw it in Florida.
There's something happening in the
story.
Something crazy.
Yeah,
it's,
it's almost squaws I spiritual
political.
It's,
there's something happening because the
left has tried for far too long to
suppress the movement of ideas and it's
free speech and dialog and discussion.
But what candace believes,
which I'm in full support of,
and I want to help her in every way
possible,
is that the African American community
has been totally,
um,
dis served,
for lack of a better term by the modern
Democratic Party and that they are
disproportionately more poor.
They're disproportionally in worse
circumstances than people of every other
ethnic or racial group.
But why is that?
It's not because Americans are more
racist country then we were in the 1960s
in fact,
no one with a straight face could
possibly say that yet African Americans
are poor today than they were in the
1960s.
So what happened to use a Hillary
Clinton term?
America did not get more racist.
America got significantly less racist.
There's still racism in this country,
but a lot of it has been eradicated if
not reversed it.
What happened is that we as Americans
supported one of the most,
you know,
I would say contentious political and
social programs,
which was the great society where we
deincentivize the black community from
making good choices.
We incentivized women to say single and
have babies.
We destroyed public sector education by
reinforcing the public sector,
teacher unions and disallowing school
choice.
I'm rewarding bad teachers and keeping
communities perpetually poor.
Um,
we I think really did a disservice by
um,
starting this war on police in the last
couple of years,
which most police officers are there for
the betterment of the communities that
they police.
And we have started this narrative that
America somehow an inherently racist
country and African Americans are poor
because we're a racist country.
The data does not reflect that.
It's because we have created a,
a set of government policies and ideas
that have not incentivized African
Americans to continue,
like make good choices that breakout of
poverty.
And as Ben Shapiro says,
you make these three choices.
You get married before you have kids,
you graduate high school and you get a
job.
You can break out of poverty in this
country and we,
and you can look to all three of those
things.
We have government programs that either
discouraged or deincentivize every one
of those choices,
especially for African American
community and candace growing up from
the poor family growing up as a,
you know,
African American woman in this culture
and the society can talk about it a lot
better than I can.
I can only talk about it from an
outsider.
She's an insider,
which in today's time unfortunately buys
you a lot more institutional
credibility,
which it really shouldn't.
I mean that's the irony.
It's,
it's,
it's sort of using identity politics
against itself.
Would you almost half,
which you almost have to do it because
if,
for example,
you always say this,
if I say free enterprise is the greatest
way to solve poverty,
and candace says it,
it doesn't make it any more or less are
true just because she's a black woman.
Right?
Truth is truth.
No matter who says it,
but the left somehow has a value,
you know,
um,
a lot higher of certain people saying
it.
But you know what,
if identity politics is what we have to
play,
then so be it.
And candace understands that,
especially on college campuses.
Black students will listen to her a lot
more likely than they'll listen to me
and I believe that she can continually
build a movement around these core set
of ideas and values and principles and
she gets it.
Cause she used to be one of them.
She used to be a leftist.
She understands who these people are and
she understands how to fight them and
how to persuade.
And we're lucky to have her as our
director of urban engagement at turning
point USA.
I know you don't like drug references,
but when I had her on I said,
you know,
for me it was like the red pill is like,
I was like slowly drinking it like tea.
She said she snorted it all the power to
hurt you as long as done in the harm.
Someone else do whatever you want to do
with your life.
I want it to end with you in a slightly
awkward position.
Here we go.
One of your employees that,
there we go.
It's very good.
You're doing great stuff.
I'm thinking forward to,
uh,
getting out on the road with you and
what you're doing.
I'm awesome at the end of that week
because you were smiling.
So I'm like,
I literally,
at one point,
I could not smile anymore.
I can't,
we're,
we're in our students.
Just great.
I mean,
they were just,
and by the way,
speaking of standing ovations,
I mean,
candice got a massive,
massive ovation.
Should be about a cent.
I mean,
here's the thing,
that's the diversity of ideas is we will
give a standing ovation of people,
even if we don't agree with what they
have to say completely.
Right.
And that's,
the left won't do that.
It's like,
get out of my room,
get out of mice,
get out of our,
you know,
lecture hall.
And,
uh,
it's a movement around true tolerance
and true discussion of ideas and we're
going to win.
All right,
well,
to find out more about Charlie's 2028
campaign for presidency,
follow him on twitter at Charlie Kirk
11.